ce n'est pas facile de se projeter dans
les vacances estivales c'est ainsi et ce
n'est pas seulement parce qu il fait
gris c'est surtout devenu très compliqué
de se déplacer entre les pays en europe
avec la pandémie
chaque pays imposent des restrictions
aux voyageurs des restrictions souvent
différente
avant de vous laisser entrer la plupart
des pays exigent des résultats négatifs
de test de dépistage
mais attention certains types de tests
utilisés en espagne par exemple ne sont
pas reconnus en france il ya aussi
l'isolément qui est obligatoire dans
plusieurs pays
il ya souvent des exceptions qui varient
cependant d'un pays à l'autre
bref voyage et c'est compliqué c'est ce
que l'europe espère simplifier l'europe
va créer un certificat vert vert comme
dans ses vers vous pouvez y aller c'est
une sorte de passeport sanitaire qui
continuera la preuve que vous n'êtes pas
contagieux c'est peut-être le résultat
négatif d'un test de dépistage
la preuve d'anticorps après une guérison
pour encore une vaccination compléter le
tout accessible sur votre téléphone ou
sur papier disponible dans toutes les
langues
grâce à un code qr n'y a bien sûr des
impératifs économiques dans tout cela le
vieux continent dépend des voyageurs
d'affaires et aussi des touristes
d'ailleurs les pays du sud le portugal
l'espagne l'italie la grèce espère
beaucoup du retour des visiteurs pour
garantir la fiabilité du certificat
sanitaire union européenne s'appuie sur
une technologie reconnue de protection
des données personnelles
cependant il faudrait quand même
composer avec quelques inconnues
scientifiques notamment à l'efficacité
des vaccins sur les variants leur impact
sur la transmission du virus ou encore
la durée de leur protection
il faudra peut-être que ce
laisser-passer viennent avec une date
d'expiration
une date qui évoluerait avec les
connaissances scientifiques en france on
se demande si ce genre de technologie
pourrait permettre non seulement de
traverser plus rapidement les frontières
mais aussi d'accéder à des lieux qui
sont aujourd'hui fermées
comme des cinémas des restaurants
l'avantagé serait de pouvoir retracer
rapidement les personnes à risque encore
de nouvelles contaminations intéressant
mais aussi inquiétant
n'y at il pas là une façon de suivre les
citoyens à la trace n'y at il pas là
aussi une façon subtile de leur imposer
la vaccination
l'idée française ne fait pas partie du
projet européen
elles pourraient être développées à part
un peu à l'image de ce que font
certaines compagnies aériennes
si tout va bien l'union européenne aura
son certificat vert numérique en juin en
espérant que les touristes soient aussi
au rendez vous